welcome everybody thanks all for joining
i'm happy to be talking at my data and
for the opportunity to
share my
views mostly
um yep so the name of my talk is
simplification office of as a service
and
going forward
a little bit about me so
i'm essentially a frustrated python data
scientist
in addition to what you've already heard
about me
about this talk so overall i would
summarize it as mostly a rant there's
some
part common sense advice
and yeah some tips overall suitable
audience would be
software developers data scientists data
engineers pretty much everyone who reads
writes code that's not meant for just
personal consumption
and yeah i mean the code that you write
today maybe six months later you don't
understand that code so anything
any any person who writes code that's
not just throw away code
just to get it working right now and
never having to look at it
it's for everyone
and hope uh you would find some
something useful
so before we really talk about the tech
stack i would like to um take a moment
and make you think about
this quote
so just read
yeah pretty straightforward right daddy
what did you bring that book that i
don't want to be read too out of up for
so and that is like what
i don't understand
and
basically the kid doesn't like this book
and is asking his dad why did you get
this book
and that's exactly the point that i'm
trying to make here that
you can simplify some things you don't
need to have a
single long sentence in which all the
information is there
and this this concept in
cognitive psychology
which is called our brain is a cognitive
miser so there's a cost to think there's
effort involved there's some energy that
you want to spend on it there's
obviously some time
involved so
when the brain wants to do something and
to get to doing that thing it needs to
use some tools for example then
the brain doesn't really want to spend
any time trying to figure out how to use
the tool
the tool should be apparent the api for
example should be obvious because when
things are obvious and things are clear
the feeling of competence is there
otherwise even when you're doing things
right you're like unsure but maybe
there's something i'm doing wrong
maybe there's some uncertainty around it
so this is what the brain is telling me
i just want to sit back and relax
don't make me think
and just a side note this is also the
name of a very good book uh for ui ux
developers
moving on getting to python now since
here at pi data
so travis olivant is the founder of
anaconda and he's also um a co-founder
of num focus and yeah people often
always discuss about why python is so uh
popular etc and what he said was
python lets you do a lot without
demanding a lot of you it lets you think
which is exactly what i said before you
want to do something
you using some means
to be able to do that you don't really
want to
get into technicalities of that means
so you don't you shouldn't be demanding
too much from your user you you let them
think about what their problem is that
they're trying to solve and that's what
makes python very popular which is
something i really agree to
um it's almost like english when you
start learning python of course there
are many technicalities which you um
encounter
when you yeah have some experience with
it but more or less it's nice the ui
experience overall i would say it's
pretty nice that's why we are here
that's why the ecosystem is thriving so
much
but it's all it's not always so
simple
or straightforward let's talk about some
entry barriers which might be
affecting say your product or just
python as itself um
in for greater adoption
there is this quote
which i took from the zen of python
which is
there should be one and preferably only
one
obvious way to do it right you should
make the code clear the user should have
access to some
clear
accessible api which is obvious you
don't have to spend a lot of time trying
to figure things out juggle things here
and there but
of course
the first thing that you do when you set
up your
project or you check out some nice
python library is to set up your python
environment
and that's already asking a lot because
there's not one way to do it there are
like so many ways to do it maybe qanda
is not even there oh no anaconda
but uh yeah and if you use so many
different ways you you can use
virtual van virtual and wrapper pip and
poetry conda what not you can install
using pip app true and every time you
use something it if you install the same
uh package for example with different
ways they they have their own parts and
you can mess some something up and a few
months later you're like i don't
remember how i installed this one
and stuff like that so it can be very
very confusing
um for starters
and sure most of you i assume um are
experienced much more experienced than
me
but
yeah for someone who's just starting out
um it's kind of off-putting you don't
really want to
have to think about python path then
yeah it's a bit difficult initially i
would say
and
the junior developers who just start
fresh maybe just out of college or
something
usually you see them asking the seniors
ah i don't understand my environment is
not working properly and it's not just
them i mean today itself when i was
trying to set things up for the demo i
yeah i struggled with setting setting up
my jupiter which is which i love of
course
moving on
okay so there's this library request
which i find personally very elegant um
and
just
the api is nice everything you want is
clear you don't have to think so much
yes it's about http requests exactly
and this snapshot i've taken from pi pi
um the two point
the version 2.7.0
and let's look at what how they want to
describe the request repository and how
they describe the project in general
python http for humans
exactly
we write code for humans
we want it to be read we want it to be
used by other humans for machines we
have machine code
that's not the point right we want our
tools that we build our machine learning
tools or even simple utilities to be
used by humans it should be easy
or simple for other humans to be used
not co-developers who would be happy to
deep dive into some
obscure end of your code base and figure
it out for you open up pr already
it's for regular humans
another interesting bit from the snape
the same snapshot that i shared with you
is um yeah this description so yeah
that's what they say most existing
python modules for sending http requests
are extremely verbose and cumbersome
python's built-in url 2 module provides
most of the http capabilities you should
need but the api is thoroughly broken it
requires an amount enormous amount of
work even method overrides to perform
the simplest of tasks
things shouldn't be this way not in
python well not just in python things
shouldn't be this way period things
should be simple
and there's a reason now
uh requests is
kind of ubiquitous i mean
yeah i had heard about requests before i
even knew about url too because it adds
value in terms of the simplification
this nice api this
nice tool that you can use without
having to yeah
read the github repository of how it's
supposed to work etc
i hope
um yeah i get across my intent
i'm not bashing any uh repo on any of
the examples i'm just
obviously very frustrated and want to
get across a message that
yeah you may build a very cool library
but unless it's easy for the users to
use it and easy for other developers to
chime in the traction
might be a bit difficult
let's take an example of this very cool
library that a friend of mine actually
showed me
when i described the idea of this talk
to him so this is gpt neo x very nascent
library of course so we shouldn't be
expecting too much
um but what it says is this is an
implementation of model parallel gpt 3
like models and gpus based on deep speed
library
it's designed to be able to train models
in the hundreds of billions of
parameters hundreds of billions of
parameters
or even larger
this representative under development
and may change rapidly without warning
okay
yeah we get that
and
requirements everything you need
everything you need
to get started running the code can be
installed via pip so you can just
install the requirements and you're good
to go that's what i
like
and if you have a look at their github
um yeah they do give you some pointers
so you first you should have to make
sure that you're in the environment with
python 3.8 or later
you should have dodged so by torch
installed
and then you just run this uh
requirements txt
okay then there's you may but may sounds
like it's optional so
let's see how it goes i'll switch to
the demo now
and i hope you can see it
now one thing about this is
since it took quite a bit of time i've
already done the steps and i would just
like to show it to you around
so added python version okay python 3.8
which is good
it freeze torch yes we have
um python dodge
it talked about it should be more than
one point eight point zero so we are
already put there now let's just do the
install the requirements let's wait wait
wait wait
are
[Music]
i see an error exit status one
um
but i don't understand what's going on
here there's some configuration missing
here
and
even then it's still continuing
doing some more checking more checking
so lots of red blob stuff
and failed building wheel for mpi for py
okay ah there's more
and then i don't basically understand
what's going on here because it's yeah
just talking about mpi programs not
being able to import
now
what i then could do is basically check
out this library
and see
um
what it says about this cuda pi which
they had described earlier here that you
may need to change the version of this
so this gives me a hint that maybe it
has something related to it with koopa
kuda
okay so i look for the
repository
and
i search for kudapai and i find this
obscure file which says one bit adam
and
there i find kudapai and it asks me
to install something like this
which also doesn't work so i basically
search for this
on
cool and this is what i find about
coupon that these are the requirements
that we need so
the first requirement is nvidia kukuda
gpu from google toolkit and python uh
these these versions above so the first
requirement nvidia kudo gpu is not there
in maddox but
that's not at all clear
from
um
the description about gpp neox
clearly
you can install
everything you need to get started
running the code can be installed by a
pip
except an nvidia food gpu we are not
that not there yet it doesn't help us
with installing nvidia gpu yes
so that's the point now i don't think
i'm ever gonna even try using this um
this uh library because this is
basically my guess i tried to look at
the readme went to the library that i
did need and there i found that there is
a requirement that my laptop currently
doesn't
satisfy
that does not mean
that
that will already fix it because the
error message that i got i don't
understand it at all
but yeah
that's what i'm talking about if the
user
is
if a new developer has to spend
more than a few minutes or
you know 10 minutes or something to be
able to get the setup ready and if they
want to be um
say contribute as a developer and if
they want to run the tests if it takes
more than half hour to have like just
check it out install everything and run
all the tests and see okay the build is
fine
they're not gonna use it i mean you will
try to find another substitute for this
library unless it adds so much
new
utility that you can't find anyone else
only then would you take the pain of
going through all the trouble to have a
working setup
yeah so just to um
collaborate more such experiences uh on
this post on hacker post so
beginner python user and he need to he
needs to rank he or she i don't know
um
are they
yeah so i've been doing a bit of python
the last few weeks for some image
processing and computer vision tasks
using opencv and numpy i have to say all
together it's pretty miserable developed
speed
another thing
api usage errors even those where
invariants are checked at runtime are
ridiculously under informative opencv
for example
does quite a bit of runtime sanity
checking on the shape and type of
arguments of its methods but somehow
even simple details as to which
parameter is the cause of the error
don't get reported in the stack trace
severely increasing the cognitive load
required to identify the mismatch which
is what
was the initial point
not fun when multiple arguments to an
api are the result of a chain of numpy
magic data among munchie
this may be a open cv complaint more
than python but
there's i mean it's very popular and
it's very difficult to find um
a user a
library which has a big user base but a
shitty um
interface
or readme etc because most of these
libraries which have a bigger
user base either they had
a great user experience already which
led to their adoption or they invested
heavily
once there they got some
traction
okay and how can you make
the user experience of people using your
aiml or even just regular python tool
better is for example using informative
errors
let's take an example of
python since it's pi data we start with
renting wordpad
so i have a very simple file in which um
yeah i have a dictionary a
which has
two
elements foo and bar
with some values
and i forgot to close the
curly braces here
and then when i run it
i get this error
on the next line
you see what i'm talking about the
syntax error is on the next line
and i'm sure we are all used to this
like yeah people who have background
from other languages like c plus plus
are also always sure okay there's a
colon missing must be in the left uh if
this is this colon missing should be in
the previous line but for someone who's
just starting out it's very confusing
and yeah let's just say it's not nice
but python
uh 3.8 is what i had used here
and
python actually the most recent python
version 3.10 has already made things
simpler for us so they already listen to
all the complaints about this so this
got released in october 2021 actually
i think
um and when i run the same file
here i get the syntax error in the
line where the error is so i forgot to
close this
um
curly braces which is what we want
and
yeah i mean of course
not a lot of people here can change so
much about
python interpreter but these things
happen in the libraries we worked on all
the time
sure in open source and especially the
libraries which have
uh
some decent developer base these things
are not so often but when you're
building something or maybe when you're
building something internally in your
company and you know like yeah they're
these 10 smart people they would
understand i don't need to worry about
fixing things to
like
making things idiot proof so to say
because they're smart people it doesn't
work like that because they might leave
new people might join you don't want to
spend
you know um
the new folks
uh some you don't want to spend like
hours explaining simple stuff to new
folks you want them to get started
quickly and really understand what's the
problem your product is trying to solve
instead of getting into these
technicalities so
yeah the point i'm trying to make is
make the flow as fluid as possible for
your users make the user experience
great it should be delightful
[Music]
okay
next thing that you can do apart from
adding informative errors is you fail
clearly
i'll tell you what i'm trying to say so
show me up front what is wrong
so imagine
uh there's a rep there's a library and
your developer or we just
want to contribute to open source or
something like that and you run the
tests so that's the first thing you do
you check it out you
install it locally and you run tests and
see if the build is fine
and then it's not fine let's just say
and instead of really telling you what's
not fine they give you something like
this so you don't buy this and they say
your test field too bad you can find out
why here in some
random
compilation of uh
characters that this is the name of the
log file you have to go find it out
and good luck if you can understand the
log
and to be honest this is what i've seen
in
um
yeah in the companies that i've worked
for this happens and this happens all
the time
sure you won't find so much of this in
open source because yeah
you want the developer experience to be
much nicer there and in companies since
you have
these experts who have been working on
yeah those repos for years yeah they
don't really
yeah bother
me taking care of newbies so much
because you know
only experts are working
and if you think this is worse
it can be much worse
so one of the tools that i work on right
now
when so there when you run tests it
fails
so you get to know
something is failed
and then you don't know which where to
find logs
and the way to find logs is to go to the
readme because then you there it's
explained that if you run this test and
here's the log if you run this test and
this is the law which when i just
started out when i
did like the first
uh feature development
i was like oh my god where am i
and
these things happen i mean it's not just
everyone wants to have good user
experience but it's about priorities you
prioritize future development that ah if
we build this feature more more
customers will uh using will be using
your product but
maybe just make things easier for them
to use and a lot of you know morons like
me would already be on board
yeah
not just feel clearly you failed early
and let's just um take an example
for this um
yeah so this is very simple um example
just to get across this point
i have this python notebook that you
should be able to see
and
yeah so there's this
function long computation and there's
another function in which you're
validating something
and basically let's just assume there's
some long running step here i'm just
using um sleeping for three seconds
but i'll just say what happens so
only after
three seconds of having run this
function wrong competition do i get the
assertion error
for
this
and then i can see okay dot should not
be in the name
so i mean this sounds very simple so
every one of you will say no no i i
would never do this
that's stupid
i've never seen this
but i can give you um
an example of something that i had
experienced in um at my work
so there's something called simulations
that we run for our customers for
different parameters
not so important but usually since the
data is like many months of data or
something like that uh these simulations
run like
four hours
so the work that i was doing uh
that set of simulation like for that
amount of data it was taking like eight
hours so what i used to do is trigger a
simulation just
before
going to work uh going home and then
next morning i would have the results
which i could analyze and so on
and basically
we had a function like
long computation which was called run
simulation and we were doing we were
reading the data and doing all kind of
um
long running computation and in the end
we were writing the
data set for analysis or further
analysis
using a very nice
library
and
the problem is since that library was
doing some validation on the
yeah some of the inputs so
yes there's some
for running simulation function there
were couple of inputs
which were not really needed for the
long running
computation but only when we write it
which happens to be
analogous to this
function
and
the the validation happened much later
than the long-running stuff so the next
day when i came into work waiting for
the results to analyze them i would see
an error
which
i could have avoided if i had known
about that error already as soon as i
triggered
to talk about that example so the
there's this uh open source library
called cathode which is very nice uh in
which you can
store
uh big data in
form of rk files um
in flat format on store and whatever
it's very nice very useful use it a lot
in fact it was developed by um
luyonder originally
and let's look at this so
this is
some pandas data frame that i created
and i want to store this data frame as a
data set using this library
and
so
how do i use it i have to provide a
couple of things so store data city uid
ah uuid what is that
let's have a look
so just to give you um some background
so there's this um uuid stands for
universal unique identifier
and it's a string it's a way of
generating
ids in the form of string so it contains
[Music]
so it expects a uuid here but let's see
what happens if i don't provide a uuid
i use this which is clearly not a
standard uuid doesn't have the whatever
whatever format it also includes
underscoring steps instead of hyphen so
does that does it work
well
i'm getting some metadata so seems like
it's stored let's check
yeah i am also able to read it so it got
stored even though
the standard are not being followed
maybe
the nice thing that um
they did was to
take care of the new id and make it more
readable but
if i change
a bit of
this string
to be this and then i get an error
because the validation is different
i guess i have to
speed up yeah so this was the second
demo
in which i explained this some links
that you can refer to um another tip
would be if you have a cli based tool
would be when you make these typos it
would be good to have do you mean this
argument so i can get if you write get
splash it tells you do you mean it stash
so i would talk a little bit
about accessible documentation uh for 30
seconds i'm sorry so if you have good
documentation it makes it easier for
users it also makes it easier for you
yourself because then you don't have
to spend time um to on-boarding users
you should ideally include tutorials how
to writes and references and they have
different purposes learning
problem and information orientation
and there are different tools like
things
doctors et cetera which can make things
much easier for your users
um your documentation should be easy to
navigate and thank you all for joining
i'm sorry i couldn't um
show you more demos about the talk but i
would be happy to connect on gather or
slack
thank you all